[TRAIN HORN]
[BRAKES HISSING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
For the members of our campus
community, this station is an
important link to the Princeton
Junction Station, and from
there the rest of the country
and a lot of the world.
I myself have been riding the
Dinky since my student days--
which, alas, I confess were
now more than 30 years ago--
and I continue to ride it today.
While the opening of the station
is an important milestone
in the Arts and Transit
Project, much work
is still to be done to
complete that project.
I hope you will join
us in looking forward
to the completion of a
project that will animate
this neighborhood with
a glorious combination
of artistic and communal spaces.
Thank you.
It's a pleasure to
be with you today.
Wonderful to celebrate the
opening of the facility.
[APPLAUSE]
LIZ LEMPERT: The Dinky may be
the shortest scheduled commuter
rail line in the
United States, but it
has a long and storied history.
It's become the
unofficial symbol--
not just of the university,
but of the town.
We love our Dinky.
We're passionate
about our Dinky.
And we believe in the
importance of public transit
and the vital connection it
provides for all Princetonians.
And we stand here today,
eager to work in partnership
with the university, the New
Jersey Transit, and the state
to ensure that this new
chapter for the Dinky
is going to be its most
successful one yet.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[TRAIN WHISTLE]
[CHEERS]
LYDIA CORNETT: I'm from
Baltimore, Maryland,
and I use the Dinky.
I do Princeton,
Trenton to Baltimore,
so I use it pretty
much all the time.
I think the new station's
really cool-- very futuristic.
And I appreciate the
heated waiting room.
KEMY LIN: I'm a
senior in art history.
We actually take lots of
trips to visit art museums
and galleries in
New York, so it'll
be wonderful to stop
at the new station.
And we can grab food
from the Wawa right
before we get on the
train-- very convenient.
And I'm really excited about
the architecture as well.
[TRAIN HORN]